[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast if
you would please hit the Subscribe
button I really appreciate it today I
have G GA is an award-winning somatic
sexologist she's an author founder and
creator of the erotic blueprint
breakthrough you've got to go take that
test and she was in Netflix sex love and
goop and she also has a book coming out
called your blueprint for pleasure in
fact that's kind of her motto and Mantra
in life and with her people she work
with is like more pleasure um and the
thing that you'll realize is that it's
not necessarily just like go have more
sex have more orgasms it's like pleasure
comes in so many different ways it's
about feeling more confident more
comfortable warming the body up moving
energy there's there's so many ways so
you know first going into like what is
Tantra I think of it like it's just sex
but it's so much more and then of course
into the blueprints and you know you'll
be able to probably identify what yours
is so we get into that stuff and we get
into porn
polyamory
self-pleasure all kinds of you know
everything around sex like what and then
of course what do couples deal with and
what do they you know what is what is in
the way of having a good sex life I'm
not going to say that I am like oh yeah
I talk about sex all the time but it was
very easy and G makes it very easy and
so I hope that you learn and enjoy a lot
from this episode I feel like it's going
to be a lot like basically like the five
love languages which has become such a
common thing for people to know what it
is but you're going to know like your
one or two signs like your one or two
ways of receiving love and after this
you're going to know your one or two
ways of receiving pleasure so enjoy hey
exciting Announcement by Optimizer Black
Friday mega sale is happening now and
will last through the entire month of
November and listen carefully because
this Mega deal is available only for my
listeners with only my code we all know
the importance of of sleep when it comes
to our overall well-being and while some
might say you can't buy a good night's
sleep I'm here to tell you that yes you
absolutely can I'm talking about
magnesium breakthrough from bi Optimizer
there's a true GameChanger in the Quest
for a better night's sleep it's a
product I trust because it combines all
seven critical forms of magnesium into
one convenient bottle so keep in mind
that when you supply your body with
these essential magnesium forms you're
in for an incredible upgrade magnesium
supports a balanced inflammatory
response promotes healthy restorative
sleep relaxation calmness and a better
stress response buy Optimizer the Black
Friday mega sale is happening right now
and Lasting through the entire month of
November the biggest discount you can
get and amazing gifts with purchase are
available only on my page by optimizers
tocom danan with the code Dan tenet
checkout choose Health this Black Friday
your well-rested calmer and healthier
self will thank you remember it's
bioptimizers
docomo code Dan 10 this is a gonna be a
fun
one it's interesting there's this pause
there because literally the first thing
I wanted to ask you about was why this
why is sex such a taboo topic like how
did we get here
because everyone does it eventually for
the most part I would almost guess
really everyone does it including
animals so why is such a weird topic to
talk about what's the big deal I think
for me this journey of unraveling why
don't we talk about sex why is sex so
taboo I think it comes from a lot of
different perspectives but my deepest
truth around it is that sex is so
incredibly powerful that it helps us
remember who we are and there is a taboo
as Alan watt said of knowing who we
truly are and who we deeply are and so
this taboo of sex as a tool especially
when used consciously to remind us of
our own power and our own magnificence
and our own
creativity that's taboo and so there has
been a taboo about sex because there's a
taboo of knowing who we are and sex gets
us closer to that uh earlier this year
I've gotten far more interested in the
topic and exploring its history and its
power and earlier this year I read the
magdalin manuscript and ah one of my
favorite favorite favorite books yeah
and just
sort of taking that in just the the true
power is the right word that sex has on
our reality on our power itself the
power of the of it ging power you know
and just even the
historical context with Jesus and Mary
Magdalene and you know using sex magic
to strengthen the his C body and just
manifesting things it's kind of crazy
yeah you're talking my language here
I've just spent a lot of my life
studying Mary Magdalene in Christ and I
just got back from Paris where I was
performing my oneperson show and the
oneperson show is about this story of
Magdalene in Christ using this energy of
sacred Union and Sexual Energy to you
take the polarities of masculine and
feminine bring them into Union for the
manifestation of this energetic body and
so I love the story of Magdalene and
Christ and really I think it's
interesting how we've suppressed the
story in spirituality that sexuality is
a big part of that and we've suppressed
the story of the feminine in
spirituality and the actual teachings
and wisdom that have come from that I
think it's one of the biggest mistakes
of religion is actually to separate you
know and not have the feminine as part
of the teaching and teachers and
priestesses who are teaching these
historical and very very powerful
techniques and this is where we get into
Tantra and you know talking about the
power of sex as a tool in Tantra and
that Aeros gamos being SE sacred Union
in from the Greeks but then when we look
at the myuna rituals in Tantra or
tantric Tibetan Buddhism and we start to
really learn that maybe God wasn't just
a a man in the clouds you know God has
feminine and masculine in aspects and
it's actually the union of that I think
we're Oneness who is remembering
tuness a lot of times people teach that
we're tunist remembering Oneness but
we're already Oneness learning how to
play tuness so I was thinking about like
this like alchemical marriage or like
this Union of the masculine and feminine
and then I was thinking about how in in
so many different ways because like the
nature of reality is also a big
fascination of mine and how things quite
are quite fractal and nature and so the
patterns reemerge in different places
and then I think about divide and
conquer and so like whether it's red
versus blue or whether it's masculine
and feminine but like you divide people
and then it's easier to conquer when
they're not when it's when they're not
unified like how do this this happen
like how and then and then take us
through the process of that is is is
that the right way to is it Al
alchemical marriage the right right
thing to use to describe yeah I I love
that term alchemical marriage because I
think a lot in sexuality we think of
chemistry between two people but I'm
less interested in chemistry I'm more
interested in the Alchemy between two
people and like you just said like you
know we have history you know we're
we're at our whim of our biochemistry or
we're at the whim of attraction in
chemistry but if the intention in coming
together with another person is how do
we create Alchemy we're in a really
powerful place and so I love that you
use alchemical Union for you know
describing this very powerful experience
that we can have through sexuality and
it's I think it's been forgotten and I
think one of the reasons why we live in
such a polarized state is because with
in the polarized State we get to play a
different
game it's like through polarity that we
actually learn who we truly are
sometimes um and and I also think it's
through polarity that we have the
universe that we have we have a
dichotomy within us that we're exploring
because if we're always in in Union then
we don't get to explore I always say
it's so lucky that we have these bodies
and then we get to
explore sensation and touch and taste
and through the senses I think sometimes
spirituality teaches like let's get away
from the senses and the body is bad and
the flesh is bad there's actually also a
path and that's why Tantra was created
for the left-handed path of of t Contra
is let's go through the body let's go
through the senses let's use pleasure
for our own Awakening and our our human
aliveness and it is about being both
human and spirit and that dichotomy it's
a yes and both I think when we see them
as separate then they become even more
separate but when we can see oh
masculine and feminine are actually one
it's a yes
and yeah I like that because it's all
like it's like the things that I've
experienced you know in the last five or
so years of my life it's the same hole
like it's like it's a Continuum it's
just one side or the other of this
Continuum so when do we know when
something is actually hot versus when do
we know some when something's actually
cold and it's kind of just a
Continuum and and and the masculine and
feminine you're saying is the same
too so how does sex play into that then
how do we use sex to create Alchemy like
how do we actually back up since you
just talked about Tantra let's talk
about Tantra what's
Tantra Tantra is Liberation through
expansion expansion through Liberation
and it's a form of yoga there's many
different tantas so there's white Tantra
which is more of a meditation based
Tantra there's pink Tantra which is a
very heart centered that utilizes the
White and the red Tantra together that's
my lineage I came from a pink Tantra red
Tantra is much more of like sexual or
gastic what the more the taboo um but if
we're going to go really taboo that's
black Tantra or Agora Tantra and that's
where we get into like the really taboo
types of sexuality which I'm I'm really
into studying how do we transmute these
darker energies if we're going to use
again polarities dark and
light I see it as a Continuum as well
not like opposites but this the Agora
tantricas would take something that felt
very dark or taboo or wrong and
transmuted into unconditional love like
so like for example they would have sex
in a cremation grounds in India or do
their meditations and cremation grounds
because that someone's dying it's
something that we consider very dark or
you know not not a place to meditate
it's not the temple where you're
meditating you're meditating in the
creation grounds but the idea again is
like we're going to take death we're
going to take suffering human suffering
and we're going to transmute that into
unconditional love we're going to
utilize that for our own Awakening and
they consider that a very Advanced
Tantra because with that very Advanced
Tantra it's easier to meditate in the
temple than it would be you know to
meditate and make love and do sacred
Union and Alchemy in a cre I don't know
maybe some people would think different
meditating in a temple or church that be
like on your
background yeah and so Tantra is a way
is a tool is a methodology is a science
that helps us to feel Union again and um
again different ways in which all the
different tantricas approach that
Kashmir Tantra for example based on like
shiism uh that's very non-u so it Go
takes you into a non-d du State of
Consciousness and I love that as well
it's like well how do we explore all
these states of Consciousness where it
isn't like one is better than the other
I think that's a really integral
approach of looking at all the different
tantas and going well let's visit and
explore all of these and what feels
really good what feels really
pleasurable that's always my one of my
mottos is how can it be more pleasurable
how can orgasm how can pleasure how can
we utilize that energy to have these
Awakenings of
ourselves and that's really exciting to
think about of we can do this in
pleasure we don't have to do it in
suffering I like that a lot so when we
when I feel like most anybody body
including myself generally speaking you
know you think about tantric sex or you
think about t Tantra and you think about
just sort of like some state of ecstasy
some state of like prolonged ecstasy
perhaps where you're able to you know
you sort of step outside the normal
pattern or rhythm of something and
there's a there's the the body and
breath and like your mind is used to
sort of create this container that's
more expansive
and lasts longer than the norm so what's
what about that is accurate and where
what am I missing beyond that so that I
can get a better complete feel for like
what Tantra really
is the ecstasis is something that I
think we start with is going into these
ecstatic prolonged
orgasm uh States and there's nothing
wrong with those states of consciousness
of course like yes let's go into these
ecstatic States let's experience all
that there is to experience within this
human body of all that is erotically
possible of all the states of ecstasy
that we can go
into and then there's like to me the
ultimate orgasm is that non-dual State
of Consciousness where you recognize
that everything was birthed out of an
orgasmic frequency and that's it's it's
you become one
with everything and there's the
annihilation of yourself in that moment
of orgasm there's an annihilation of
everything you've known into
something that we don't even have words
to describe what are the practices or
what is the thinking and then feeling
that allows you to get into that space
because surely you don't just arrive
there at some like fantastic orgasm one
day where you're like I'm one with
everything like you have to have some
awareness to the that idea itself so
what's the
pathway go slow and gentle I mean people
do have spontaneous experiences of that
but it often comes with like headaches
and physical body experiences and also
like I don't understand what happened to
me so it's hard to integrate on the
other side so it can be a little
disconcerting actually just had a really
big spontaneous event happen um when I
was doing my Mary Magdalene
stuff in Paris I had a a spontaneous
event that lasted 30
days yeah yeah so and I had no idea like
I was sitting in a cafe in Paris and
then all of a sudden I was in ecstasy
and they had to take me back and like I
couldn't talk I was I was in a
completely different state of
consciousness and it lasted for 30 days
what tell me yeah yeah and so and that
was spontaneous and I wasn't doing
breath work or so it can happen
spontaneously but I also have been
studying this for 30 years so you know
it helped that I had those tools if I
hadn't had those tools I would have
thought like we need to put me in the
hospital you know kind of a thing but I
had familiarity with going into those
States and um and so usually it's breath
work with sex so um a simple one that
everyone can do is just in mouth mouth
breathing in and out of the mouth and
staring in each other's eyes as you're
doing it on a on a rhythm and deepening
the breath and so you're then you're
utilizing both the sexual sensation and
the breath with eye contact with
intention and that intention being to
move the sexual energy through the whole
body and through the spine and um and
getting into Rhythm into that because
that starts to create this trance it
starts to create a different state of
consciousness and then you bring it
through the body and um different
breathing techniques can do that so like
a holotropic breath work like St gra but
utilizing it during sex um can be really
powerful so I use the tools always of
breath sound movement and tension in any
thing where I'm looking to create a
state change through utilizing erotic
energy and then the other thing that I
think is really interesting is just how
our anatomy is set up how cerebral
spinal fluid works and then how we have
this neog gland in our brain that
actually ejaculates you know it releases
really yes it can so you can put
pressure on that hydraulic pressure on
your pineal gland and then that pressure
stimulates it and you ejaculation yeah
the little crystals so is that at his
events there
are people during the breath work that
have orgasms of such will be you know
know it's dead quiet and everybody's
doing their breath work and then all of
a sudden you hear somebody
going and you're like what the is going
on so is that what that is it could be
it could be that the pineal gland is
ejaculating their brain state is
changing DMT is being produced you know
or released from that from that and then
they're having an ecstatic experience as
the energy is moving up the spine and
into the brain that can create an
ecstatic experience and coming back to
you talking about ecstatic experiences
with Tantra I think the danger and
ecstatic experience is chasing the
experience and as soon as we start to
chase it we're no longer um we're in a
chasing State as opposed to being in the
actual direct experience of the state um
and so that's that's interesting to me
too because how do we maintain a
state and and not get attached to the
tool even sexuality you know we talk
about psychedelics and sexuality and
some of these tools that take us into
these I think they're natural States Of
Consciousness not Altered States Of
Consciousness you know they're expanded
from our
everyday but this Natural State of
Consciousness that is who we
are and we start to then create more of
um not a stage or a state change but it
becomes something that is that is a norm
it's a new base line for us now our new
Baseline is this state of Joy orgasm
ecstasy instead of chasing it okay since
you've achieved that at least I'm
hearing you know we're we're just
starting the conversation but for at
least 30 days you changed it for sure
but generally speaking I'm sure you've
sort of leveled up so what does that
feel like what does it feel like to
change your state on a regular on a I
don't know if May it's probably
permanent some of the levels what does
it feel like what's the what's the
difference it feels like you're embodied
you have
embodied what that experience
was and then even if something
fluctuates it's very easy to
return you know if something in life
happens you're not in resistance to
those things in life
happening you are okay here's anger and
I and accept that
anger and then the anger can flow as
opposed to there's not as much
resistance to what is showing up in
life and you notice that you've embodied
something that before was just an idea
and now you're living it and so you're
living more like you know what are some
of the ways that you get to the point
where you embody something because I I
I've experienced varying sort
of things from the state of wanting
thinking knowing embodying right like
when they become embodied there's really
like for me my my my experience of that
is it's just like there's a knowing it's
just like it just is there's no reaching
there's no no not having there's just it
just is like it's something that just is
now instead of like man I really want to
oh trying to get that or or I don't want
that it's just things that are and so
explain how we can get to like the how
how do we embody what are the pathways
to embodiment of
something Pathways to embodiment I think
that there's there are passive ways of
doing that and then there are active
ways so I'll speak to that a little yeah
and I also want to speak to a little of
like getting there I think that and this
could be a more passive just like a
Brain Change like a way of brain
changing because getting there appears
as if you're not in yeah and so there's
this also acceptance that this is and I
like saying the phrase isness is ising
all the time and the infinite is that
is and so there's that passive way of
even just feeling that like everything
is and I can I can close my eyes for a
moment and take a
breath and slow down down and be in that
place where everything just
is slow down and then there's the active
things maybe it's and I think that's
different for every person maybe it's
reading and really studying and their
path is
wisdom and their wisdom then becomes
embodied by reading it over and over and
over again and being exposed to it over
and over and over again yeah and I think
some people need to do the practices and
be in flow with their body maybe it's a
yoga practice or maybe it's making love
because we're talking about sexuality as
this tool you know maybe it's practicing
tantric sex every day um I practiced
every day for 10 years never missed my
practice and that was just part that
means practicing a breathing a breath uh
an intention was there an AC an action
too whether it was self or with yeah I
would do so I would always start with my
intention for the day in my practice and
then from there I would activate my body
in some way so that could be some kind
of yoga
practice um dancing moving shaking doing
exercise something that I could do to
really get my body
activated and then I would still my mind
so some kind of meditation um and in
Tantra we have very in the tantric
lineage that I was in we had very
specific practices we would do from like
breathing in and out of the pineal gland
type of visualizations or Mantra
something to just really still the Mind
chatter that's there and then from
stilling the Mind arousing Sexual Energy
so this could be with a partner where I
would be making love or we would do some
kind of sexual activity to really get
the sexual energy
moving um and that could mean clothed
and not even in Intercourse but
sometimes it could be
intercourse and then if it wasn't with a
partner then that would be a solo
practice of moving Sexual Energy and
starting to arouse Sexual Energy so that
could be a self-pleasure practice that
I'm doing that day or an exploration of
my G-spot something um that could be
more what we would consider sexual
blueprint or that could be all energetic
where I imagine that I'm making love
with a consort something like that um so
arousing the sexual energy and then
transmuting Sexual Energy I think that's
the most important animportant piece in
terms of what we were talking about
before with the pineal gland so you're
always bringing the energy from the root
or from the sexual centers up through
the body and transmuting that into
whatever you're manifesting if you're
doing manifestation type of practice or
if you're transmuting like I was talking
about the darker energies into
unconditional love or if the intention
is for your own Awakening or healing
that you can move that energy then and
transmute it through the body up into
the brain so with the intention at the
beginning and then the moving of the of
the sexual energy and transmuting it
those things those things go together
without having to actually do something
with moving the energy the moving of the
energy emphasizes the intention is that
the that's how I understand it is that
true absolutely absolutely so so holding
your intention and then when you move
that energy up into the higher centers
then that start starting to move that
into that manifestation realm yeah I
used to do a thing where in my uh
company they had Gia's orgasm in the um
morning every morning and uh that was
because I was doing a manifestation
practice and in that time I quadrupled
my business so you know like I like
there's something through this some's
like um J did you get your orgasm done
today that's of the
day one of our core brand values is
pleasure first so it's just part of like
pleasure to start the day pleasure to
start a meeting you know how are you
incorporating pleasure first into your
life every day I think we don't
celebrate enough in terms of even just
our wins throughout our lives and then
we go on to the next thing and the next
thing and yeah how are we really
celebrating in all of
my plant medicine Journeys and
Explorations it's generally speaking or
even if you talk to somebody that's much
older like things get simpler and it's
like just to here to be experienced like
that's what I it's just just to
experience like it's not really a lot
more than that and we are such meaning
making machines that we are always
trying to find out the who the where the
what the when the why the what next the
what happened like there's always
there's just always the next thing on to
the next thing always yeah and I think
there's something really beautiful in
resting and experience because as we
rest in experience we can rest more in
self and the beauty of just being what
and who we are and life will
unfold but it's much more enjoyable when
we're just being who we are instead of
chasing the next thing I mean I checked
all the boxes in life two 2017 I hit
like all my success all my goals I had
like the perfect life and I was just
like why do I not feel fulfilled I've
hit every success and like what's next
and I checked everything and I'm
supposed to be really happy aren't
I yeah and then I wasn't and so that's
when I went on a deeper exploration of
well what's this thing really about if
I'm not happy what is what is this about
what are we here for and I started
asking bigger questions who am I and
what's truth
and um yeah really looking
at at what was deeper beyond all of the
chasing and all of the what's next and
that's when I found myself
I'd love for you to elaborate on that
what did you find
yeah so I in 2017 I went and got my
brain scanned with Dr aan I don't know
if you know him Daniel aan I do I've
done the same thing and um they were
like you have cptsd I'm like okay well
what's that and they're like complex
post-traumatic stress disorder I'm like
all
right and so we looked at like ways to
heal it and it was really resistant and
so I started looking on my own and I
found that MDMA therapy could help with
cptsd it was one of the you know the
research from maps and those kinds of
places that were showing that and I was
like okay let's let's go explore that
you know I've done all these other tools
I've done all these other things I've
had these glimpses of who I am I've had
these glimpses through sexuality as
we've been talking about but I really
wanted to look at healing my brain on
that level and so I did my first session
my first session was an absolute miracle
I have not had a cptsd symptom since
that session yeah it was I had a I had
really lucky therapy or first session of
it was MDMA therapy MDMA therapy okay
yeah um I found a guide and you know
that's not for not everybody has that
experience and definitely psychedelics
aren't for everyone but that it was a
miracle for me the way that it worked
for me and then it was probably my third
my fourth session was was my fourth
session with the guide when I had a
complete mystical
experience and it was through this
breath I was just talk telling you about
about drawing the breath up into my I
knew how to do that I was doing like all
my Tantra and utilizing that while I was
in the
journey and all of a
sudden it was like everything went white
and I had this experience of complete
Unity with everything and you know how
do we how do we explain these
experiences is really hard to put into
words but I realized that I saw the
cosmic game like you know we're we're
all God and we decided to play this
really fun game of remembering who we
are and I I have theories now on why we
play this game I think the first one is
to experience and express like you were
talking about you know we come we come
here to have this experience otherwise
it's just nothing it's
just um we come to know who we are we
come to see you know who are we really
and we can't see each other we can't see
ourselves unless we have the opposite of
ourselves and so we create a world of
Duality and
dichotomy and we come because maybe
we're lonely there's only one so we want
Playmates so we create more of ourselves
so we can love love ourselves you know
in the shape of others I like saying I
love loving myself in the shape of you
God that's a really great
line and then um I think also because
there's
boredom so why not create an infinite
World and infinite worlds and which to
explore and express and create and
choose choose now who we are like we We
Now understand who we are so every day
now becomes a choice of what we want to
create as infinite creators well if
we're that infinite being then we would
get bored yeah that's why we got a dream
too because I think that's part of what
makes these experiences in other states
or our Natural
State ineffable because there's so much
more information in those
spaces it becomes embodied and to me in
those spaces are where I have embodied
things the deepest the
most because it's such an experience it
feels so visceral it's so real that you
because it might be our natural state
that you're like oh and it's like almost
a remembering in those places and spaces
where you go oh and then it becomes
embodied and that's just the way it is
and um and it's and it's and it's
because we are so much more than just
this experience in this state of being
asleep or um in some kind of Trance or
limited awareness of while awake um that
we we can't really hold that information
can't hold that much
information um but in those States we
can and it really feels like to me that
you get a a glimpse into just the the
vastness and like how much we really are
and that to me why I can't describe it
because there's just so much information
in such a tight little area and such a
small experience that when I use the
words it's like and then I was sitting
there and I cried because I realized
that I was supposed to like be my own
perfect partner and it's like okay
that's like a sentence or two but like
the whole experience was so freaking
huge like it was like waves and waves of
mourning and crying and there's just
like the feeling is something that you
really just can't get across it's like
trying to describe to someone who's
never had an orgasm what an orgasm is
right until you have the direct
experience of an orgasm you have no idea
what I'm talking about oh my God it's so
right okay let's get into some of the
okay let's get into the blueprints so I
tried to get um I tried to do the
blueprint I was like last night I was
like I need to findy what my exotic
blueprint is and or erotic blueprint and
so I went in and I put I have an old
very old AOL address and oh no I clicked
through and I was like whatever whatever
and then I was like why didn't I get it
and then I saw again I was like I
clicked on it again and it said if you
have an AOL or something else it's a
problem for the system and I was like
yeah so I'm gonna do it but I was
totally gonna be honest about whatever I
was I just don't know because I didn't
well maybe we'll find out as I describe
them oh yes let's do it yeah okay love
so the first one is energetic and we've
been talking a lot in the energetic
blueprint talking about Tantra and
different states and all of this so
energetics are someone who's turned on
by
anticipation space tease yearning and
longing and so the more that they have
those things the more arousal that they
feel their superpower is that they can
go into these expanded States Of
Consciousness through sexuality Oneness
experiences mystical experiences and
having multi-dimensional orgasmic states
that they can play in but the shadow
side of that is that they can get hyp
sensitive and too much too quick too
fast can shut them down turn them off
oftentimes they've had some kind of
trauma in their past that created the
hyper sensitivity that can be a
superpower or it can on the flip side be
this Shadow and a lot of people don't
know how to play energetically with
sexuality unless they've studied Tantra
or some of these other things they don't
really know how to do it so a lot of
times energetics feel like they're weird
or they're broken or they've put up an
armor so that they can be sexual with
their partner in the way that their
partner wants because people don't
understand and they misunderstand that
actually they're not sexually frigid or
shut down they're just so sensitive that
less is more it's like don't do a
cannonball into the water just dip your
finger in and let it Ripple slowly and
then a sensual is someone who likes all
of their senses being ignited so the
sensual likes the touch collapsed they
like the smells and the tastes they
bring all the beauty and Artistry to the
erotic experience so whereas the
energetic likes all the space the
sensual is like no come slow dance with
me come cuddle with me those kinds of
things and then the sensual Shadow is
getting caught in your head so you are
like wait a minute I need to call that
person oops you're just distracted by
all the things breath smells is
everything okay down there these kinds
of things are going on in your brain
instead of enjoying the pleasure um that
can really come from the sexual
experience another superpower of the
sensual is that they can have
non-genital orgasms so orgasms from I
call it crevice sex where you know
you're like somebody's crevice like the
crook of their neck or behind the knee
or the
elbow you know what the name of the
elbow here is I think it's funny so the
wenus and the
vagina
somebody actually named my
little um so yeah so like crevice you
know I had somebody go down on my armpit
once I had like the best orgasm
ever so that's the central blueprint
gotcha the sexual is someone who's
turned up by what we think of a sex in
our culture so sex in our culture being
intercourse nudity getting to the orgasm
erections wetness
the shadow side of the sexual is that
they often are just thinking about the
end goal and not really enjoying the
Journey of sexuality because they want
to get off and so they miss this
exquisiteness of all the other
Blueprints and they will often judge the
other blueprints like what's wrong with
you you know sex is sex it's easy why do
we have to do all this other stuff I
hear that a lot of times from sexuals
the superpower however from the sexual
is that sex really can be this great
orgasmic zero to 60 very quickly lots of
arousal um getting to the orgasm easily
these are some of the superpowers sex is
fun sex is enjoyable there's a lightness
to sex for a sexual what's interesting I
think between the sexual and the sensual
is the sexual needs to have sex to relax
like I'm stressed let's have an orgasm
and then like oh I feel better whereas
the sensual is like how in the world are
we having sex I'm so stressed right now
I need to go get a massage or I need to
relax before I could have sex with you
it's interesting on gender too because
we've done we've had like I think two
million people now fill out that quiz
damn and so we have like a py graph of
gender and
blueprints and it's really interesting
to see that men are actually all across
the board wow and that and there is a
high sexual but there's also really high
shape shifter and then like it's almost
the same the whole pie chart is almost
EX exactly the same now that could be
men who fill out our quiz like maybe
sexuals don't fill out the quiz as much
because they're like why explore this
but um you know it's that's fascinating
to me is how gender has played out and
that women are primarily energetic and
sensual but men are across the board
almost all of the
blueprints that's cool that's cool say
had two million people you got a pretty
good pretty good beta test going pretty
good pretty good test going yeah yeah
yeah the next one is kinky and the kinky
is someone who's turned on by that taboo
and that could be either psychological
kinky or it's impact based kinky
sensation based kinky my own partner Ian
he is a kinky primarily and I was zero
on the quiz kinky and I'm primarily
sexual and he was a zero and so it made
sense exactly like why we were complete
opposites so kinky Shadow is shame deep
shame for why am I like this why do I
like these things that are outside the
box why am I like six and a half years
into our relationship and I did not know
he was kinky cuz he had like and I'm a
sexologist I'm like how do normal people
talk about sex if my own partner you
know didn't feel safe than God for you
or he would have maybe never known
himself and been able to like really
like fully tap into his his sexuality
thank God exactly he was the first guy I
dated who had vibrators and I was like
all right we can date like you have your
own sex
toys so that was fun and then the kinky
also the superpower is endless
creativity like I can play in the realm
of Kink for the rest of my life and
never learn all the fun things there are
to do I think we have a lot of judgment
and projection about what kinky means
but really it is a broad definition
because it's anything that's taboo for
you and within that there's all kinds of
things to learn you know like if you
like ropes oh my goodness there's
shabari there's Zen meditation rope
there's like all different kinds of rope
ties that you can learn and play with
and take years of study to to do and so
that can be fun just to keep exploring
all the different things if you're bored
introduce Kink you don't need it's just
not a slip knot
or although I like really quick rope
ties personally because I'm a sexual and
I want to get to it
yeah but my partner likes all the slow
and so you know learning for that to be
my turn on how do we Bridge those gaps
maybe we'll talk
about uh and then the last one's the
shape shifter and The Shape Shifter is
someone who's turned on by all of it and
they love all of these things they want
to play in all of these things um
they're turned on by everything and in
their Shadow side they've often been
judged that they're too much and I will
say that a good reframe is you're not
too much you're just erotically
sophisticated and you're not overly
complex you just really have a depth of
sexuality that can include everything a
full spectrum you have a full spectrum
sexuality when you are a shape shifter
and my theory is that we're all shape
shifters and that's really who we are
because we are all of it full spectrum
sexuality would be exploration of
everything and all of it and inclusive
of all of it but I think we get
conditioned and programmed especially
because we have so much shame as we were
talking about the top of the show you
know we have so much Shame about sex
that we get conditioned and programmed
that this is okay or this isn't okay or
our traumas in life you know that are
unhealed still are playing out and so we
don't have holess in our sexuality yeah
and I'll also say and you're already
whole and you're not broken and we're
just integrating things that have been
disowned back into wholeness I gotta say
I'm probably the first one yeah your
eyes lit up the most when I was not the
energetic yeah yeah I think that's I
think that's probably probably the one
is it like um because there's another
super helpful test I feel like in
relationships which um the five love
languages there's usually like a one and
a two you know you kind of have like two
but there's you know there's usually two
and but there's definitely a one and I
had to pick a two is it like that with
your test or is it more yeah so we get
we have two different ones one that'll
just tell you a primary one and then we
have a more in-depth one that will give
you like percentages of every single one
that you are okay okay I I think this is
just kind of reading a little bit what
you might be I think you might be an
energetic Shape Shifter that's right and
I think you're going to love the analogy
I always use for energetic shape
shifters they're like the hyp sports car
if they were a car they're like you need
a master to drive you who like knows
just like how One to be so attuned to
your system but once once they know that
Attunement and they know in their
Mastery how to be with you you will open
up and give them a full you know
experience so I think you read that just
right and you probably actually put more
words to it than I even knew to be
honest truly I I'm not surprised because
of you know because being you but I
would say that's right that was kind of
my feeling too as I was like it's
probably Shape Shifter because the rest
are F the rest are good but there's like
energetic is definitely the the feels
one um but I can get down with it all
but I also that I think that's my
curiosity with reading the magdalin
manuscript and my you know for the last
year I've really been fascinated and
wanting to learn more about um Sex Magic
Sexual Energy and just wanting that
wanting that person that can come in and
like meet me there right like they
actually like show up and not just be
disconnected and transactional with it
or awkward or like you know have there
be issues that you know get in the way
as an energetic you're going to feel all
of that right you're going to be attuned
to when somebody's tentative and not
confident you're going to be attuned to
they're not really present with me the
number one gift anybody can give an
energetic especially an energetic Shape
Shifter is presence and awareness I
would say if I can teach one tool it
would be to have awareness and presence
with someone to be here now with another
human and that seems so simple but I
think we we you know we getting
ourselves back onto the mat or say you
know per se I like it it to like a puppy
you know when it when you're trying to
get it to pee on a newspaper the mind is
kind of like that like it wants to go
pee in the corner but you're like no no
over here on the
newspaper and that's like that present
moment so the next step in that thought
process though is now what do you do
with it and so like the first one would
be I would think for for the other
partner given I mean I suppose there's
ways to practice yourself and I do want
to get into self self-pleasure practice
stuff but um but the their partner
taking the test as well so what happens
when you're mismatched because you have
totally the experience you're the expert
and have the experience so is that like
Doomsday or obviously not not at all
it's interesting I think that people
teach a lot like oh you're sexually
incompatible or mismatched and I don't
believe that's true I think it's like
languages just like we were talking
about the love languages
where if you have somebody in your life
and you love them you're willing to
learn their
language and so all it is is skill set
you can learn someone's language and
then what's interesting is you know
you've expanded into the next blueprint
when their language becomes your turn
on and that's a learnable skill like Ian
and I for example he's kinky and in his
kinky again I had zero so I had to learn
the skill set and learn the practice of
seems like it'd be the hardest one to
learn too there's a lot to learn
especially when you have a partner who's
like no I want it exactly this way but I
want to be the bottom but I want it
exactly this way and so I had to learn
how to like navigate his trying to top
from the bottom and me like really
having the control and him being able to
surrender into exactly what he wanted
without trying to boss me from the
bottom so he just had a rule of he
couldn't talk and if he talked we get
punishments and so we had to come up
with what those were which was super fun
um and so yeah I mean just I just
learned and then eventually I found like
well what turns me on here okay well
what turns me on here is when we play
the games the psychological games I
really love psychology I love getting
inside of human psychology and so when
we're playing in a power Dynamic that's
a turn on or if he's the switch so then
if I'm in the surrendered position what
turned me on was he would tease me
energetically and not give me touch so
he would just keep teasing me and
teasing me and teasing me until I was
like please touch me yeah that's great
okay that's like a total way of teasing
is just using using the blueprints the
different blueprints to lean into things
and lean out it's not a matter of like I
touch I don't touch right it's a matter
of like I give you your language like I
exactly exactly and so then for him you
know he's kinky and didn't have any
sexual we found this really fun game
where I boss him to have sex with me so
like I own him for like a 247 period and
then I get to say like come you know
come give me sex right now and he he's
at my whim and that's the game because
now he feels like he's surrendered into
it but I get to ask for only sexual
things and
so it's super fun and we find those
crossovers it's like a VIN diagram and
you find the
Crossovers plus I think I think what's
happening is we're trying to complete
ourselves sexually and so that's why I
have a partner who has a zero has 0% in
what I'm high in and he has a 0% in what
I'm high in because we're coming into
that shape shifter
wholeness and we're utilizing
relationship as a tool to do
that that's cool what about when
someone's the same I mean it seems like
just like in languages it's easier but
you know I mean for people depends on
the sameness and it depends on what your
secondary is so if like you're an
energetic sexual so I'm a sexual
energetic I kind of flip-flop those two
who which one's higher if I was with
another energetic only that would be
really hard for me and that actually
happened I have a 20-year relationship
that is all energetic we've been 20
years whole poly thing so there too yeah
and so um why is that B what what what
is that what is the problem with two
energetics or two sexual the challenge
is if one of you wants physical touch
and one of you wants physical sex
intercourse and if one person is like
let's say they're 98%
energetic with like hardly anything else
like maybe sensual mixed in there and
the other one's an energetic
sexual then that one with the sexual is
going to want to have sexual expression
or intercourse and that could be really
challenging if one yeah if they're too
much overlap you end up just pulling the
overlap because you have them versus
getting fed into the one that might be
your number one right and then you can
get stuck too in like just doing that
thing or like two sensuals together if
they have a lot of Shadow then they
don't ever have sex because they're
stressed out all the
time yeah kind of need that sexual to be
like okay come on like well and you work
I mean being a somatic sexologist
there's like the body and there's moving
the energy and so like you know things
get stuck in the body and I've totally
experienced that with just you know life
and traumas and you know we all think of
traumas as being something really really
substantial like a car crash but they're
not and so the energy just gets stuck so
how do you know like what are some red
flags if someone has work to do to get
rid of blockages and needs some somatics
or needs some kind of healing mechanism
maybe it's you know healing your brain
maybe it's something else it's there's
there's many ways to kind of Liberate
the body and get things moving but but
what are some what are some red flags
that there needs to be a little bit more
work done to to get to a place that is
more whole yeah the the main thing is
once you know your blueprint then you
can start look at four categories one is
healing the Shadows which is what you're
talking about and within healing I'm
always looking at four things what's
happening
biochemically so is there something
going on with the hormones so let's say
you're having challenges feeling turned
on or you're having challenges with
erection something like that then we
could look at well is testosterone low
um what's happening neurochemically just
looking at the actual biochemistry of
someone so that's the first area the
second is the emotional are there
unhealed traumas or subconscious
programs running are there charges
around sexual it that have in cleared
healed worked with um I do something
called orgasmic Gates which is opening
up all of the orgasmic Gates and we're
looking for what's the content within
any area in the body where there is
holding and so if you're there's
numbness or pain okay I'll go through
that and go I feel like I have four four
Frameworks going on here I make sure
they're clear um but I'll go into the
body let's say there's a pain here and
we're looking at it in the physical
layer oh okay there's tight muscles in
the pelvic floor or there's Scar Tissue
here from childbirth there's something
here that is in the physical layer but
often times as we go through the
physical layer and we help loosen the
muscle or we help you know that bring
awareness to that area there's something
in the emotional
layer and so then we get into oh you
know I feel a lot of anger there because
whatever happened in my past and then
we're go into the anger instead of
resist it because often when those
traumas enter into the body it's because
we resisted in the moment and didn't get
to fully experience it and then and
that's why psychedelics I think are so
great for healing and definitely for me
was it allowed me to experience the
unexperienced as Stan gra talks about
where I got to go back into those
traumas that created the
cptsd and feel them feel them in a safe
space when I couldn't feel them when I
was
little and so we get move through that
so on and on that spot and then the
physical layer then we go into the
transpersonal layer and the
transpersonal is like you know oh I'm
remembering when I was in a past life or
I remember you know I'm having this
image of XYZ I don't know what it means
in allowing for that I think a lot of
times healers or people you know who are
doing body work will just be on the
physical or the emotional layer and then
we miss things that may be transpersonal
content that could be there as a result
of you know who knows karmic and all
kinds of different things that can come
up in the body that the body is still
holding and then the last layer is the
truth layer and so once we've worked
through that truth layer then we start
to see things like people going oh
they're remembering that they're one
remembering you know some truth about
the the the trauma that was there in the
body that we were working with and then
that starts to open up truth one the
truth one a little bit more because I
understood all those but then they all
felt like truth
so is like what explain just a little
bit more what the truth layer is the
truth layer may come to a realization
like oh I'm I'm one with
everything and oh that was all story or
I was making that up or truth layer
might
be now I understand who I am and I'm
unconditional love okay more like an
like a overso a overlay like a pro
perspective exactly exactly cool okay
yeah and so that's the one way that I'm
working atically that usually starts
with that emotional layer but that can
affect the biochemistry you know even
there those remembering things and I
mean everything changed for me my
biochemistry changed afterwards and I I
had such a radical shift in my whole
being just based on getting to the truth
I didn't have even have access to that
necessarily know glimpses of it but now
to have access to it shifts everything
for me you know that was my story so so
going back to these four things in the
healing realm we had biochemistry we
just talked about emotional and we also
talked about energetic so bioenergetic
what's happening on the bioenergy level
we're bioenergetic before we're anything
else so even in the cellular level there
can be things going on that can affect
our sexuality and and how we're relating
and then the last one is um physical
biochemical my mind is blanking
biochemistry emotional uh physical
physical layer we just talked we talked
about it so the physical what's actually
happening in the body so Scar Tissue
those kinds of things so those four that
I'm looking at biochemistry physical and
emotional and
energetic are always you know when we're
healing stuck in the healing we're
looking at those four and so if we're
trying to identify for ourselves or
identify possibly for someone else who
isn't able to see themselves so clearly
and you're in relationship and there's
situation it's not necessarily like I'm
looking at the the sort of um what would
what would set you off to go into those
well go into a space where you could get
some Hands-On healing work or you could
get into the energetics the physical
like would it just be awkwardness would
it just be like discomfort would it just
be like generally just like sex sex is
just like
lacking it's anywhere where you feel
charge you know some people can have
sexist lacking and it doesn't bother
them but it's really bothering their
partner and now there's there's some
kind of charge there there's some kind
of emotional content there's content
that comes up and that content could be
images that are stuck your brain keeps
seeing the same image that content could
be thoughts that ruminate that content
could be emotions that feel like they're
not processing they're just really stuck
um and that that content so thoughts
body and Body Sensations so pain coming
up um numbness in your
genitals these are all the different and
and I think we we look at the blueprints
we look at the shadow side of the
blueprint if you're dealing with any of
those
Shadows that's an opportunity for
healing but then there's also the things
like erectile dysfunction lack of
arousal just things that we think of
when we think of sex not being optimized
and optimal um any of any of those
things we want to look at these four
areas what I mean erectile dysfunction
what have you found to be the most
common reason for it in your
practice the most common reason is is
the emotional realm and the pressure
that people put on themselves you know
like sometimes like oh I didn't get an
erection once and then that starts this
Loop of issues in their brain and then
the second one is biochemis chemical
because we have so much shift in
estrogens and estrogenic prod like so
many things that are happening
biochemically and I think they're all
they're kind of tied together like we
get this Lop we get into this Loop and
this pattern with it of the biochemistry
is affecting the emotional state the
emotional State's affecting the
biochemistry and we get into a
loop what role does self-pleasure play
in sort of your sexual
expansion you have that with or with you
know like you don't have to be you do
not have to have a partner to be doing
any of this right you can or you can't
it's either what you know maybe it's
self-pleasure even if you do have a
partner yeah I I mean I have a
self-pleasure practice I do every single
day just my tonsure practice um because
pleasure
first and so I feel like it's really
important and pleasure your pleasure
practice doesn't have to be like Oh I'm
gonna be naked and have genitals and
orgasm and all of that what's your
blueprint I think we think like sexual
blueprint only when we think of SE
self-pleasure practice and um you know
if your blueprints energetic maybe your
self-pleasure practice is learning a
tantric deity practice where you're EMB
bodying vajo guini and you're become or
you're becoming the Magdalene and you're
you know you're generating some of that
you know the
IIs things that that are talked about in
the Magdalene manuscript you know where
you're really embodying that and that
becomes part of your practice is to
embody something that feels like it's
that yummy juicy energy that's my
practice right now every morning I do a
vaj yogini practice vaj yogini in
tantric Tibetan Buddhism is a diini that
transmuted Darkness into unconditional
love and so every morning I do a
practice of
embodying that so that when I walk
through my day everything becomes that
but I also feel juicy and alive and my
hormones feel healthy because I'm doing
these practices that just feel like an
embodiment of the Goddess that makes
sense I mean because like pleasure is
not just like orgasm pleasure is not
orgasm they're not the same the same
word is just feeling pleasure it's
feeling warmer and juicy it feels like
alive feeling confident feeling clear
feeling all those things that's good and
orgasm cannot be pleasurable it can be
like a genital sneeze I mean sometimes
sneezes are very pleasurable but you
know I think Ella was having lovely
sneezes over here I heard those and when
she's done with dinner every night she
has other Pleasures on herself too I let
her have it I'm like you do your thing
you do you isn't it interesting though
how we humans get shame but animals
don't they like lick their butt and oh
yeah don't have any Shame about it yeah
no no I feel shame for her like oh God
hear you over
there so so it's a good practice it's
like so self-pleasure is a way of sort
of learning about yourself it's about
pleasure first um and it's about filling
your tank yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
manifesting too I think could be a
really good big layer to inspire people
to more practice is what do you want and
incorporating that in so that you can
sort of use the energy to boost whatever
it is that you
want yeah and that can be personal that
can be for the world yeah I'm doing the
vogini practice now I'm practicing you
know every day I end with a blessing
what is my blessing and right now I'm
doing blessing for all the people who
are suffering with death and sickness
and that's my intention is that that's
something that I'm utilizing the sexual
energy to then be able to take that
unconditional love and and bless so it
doesn't always have to be it could be
personal of course but it can also be
something when we're looking at like
tantric Tibetan
Buddhism where you're really giving the
compassion to the world through our
practice what about um I feel like it's
something that I've only learned about
in the last few years years a little bit
more and um it's not something that I
watch but
porn and I don't know maybe I should but
I'm curious about its positive role
because I I think there's sides to
everything but also I'm almost more
curious about the negative role of it
that it has
because you know in the in the bit that
I know about it it's not like I've never
seen it before but I don't watch porn
and it's just so unrealistic like I
don't know if it gives guys an idea of
like how a girl is supposed to act or
how how long it's supposed to feel good
but you know I'm feeling like it's
fairly unrealistic and it's not very
sensual and it's like there's just I
don't know I'm very curious about this
about porn because porn addiction I feel
like even in in the last few years I've
heard
men it's not something that you'd think
would even come up but they'll say
something along the lines of like you
know and I don't watch porn anymore and
they're like really proud and I'm like I
didn't ask for that but it obviously is
such a big deal and it's obviously can
be such a I mean you've heard even
athletes I've heard athletes talk about
how really was controlling their life
I'd love for you to share what the you
know the the shadow side of that and and
how it's grooming people but probably
especially men but women watch
too yeah it's interesting often times
I'll say it's how you use the tool and
is it leading you back to yourself and
to embodiment and that would be the
question so I think the way that most
people are they in right relationship
with it or are they using it and so just
like any tool it can lead us to our
greatest ecstasis or it can be used
detrimentally and where the way that I
see the shadow side of it is the somatic
habit that gets formed and so if you're
sitting in front of your computer and
you're hurrying and you're getting to
like the one part is very sexual
blueprinted or often times kinky
blueprint because it feels like it's
taboo you'll see a lot of Kink and
sexual blueprint in porn and and so then
you know if you're rushing through it
you're creating a rush in your body and
that's where sometimes premature
ejaculation comes from or even the
erectile dysfunction as we were talking
about because now you've got a habit
that your body knows to get turned on
that habit becomes a rut and eventually
becomes a grave and then you can't get
turned on other ways or you're not
enjoying being with a partner because
the porn then has become the loop and
you have to keep returning to that Loop
in order to feel the turn on and there
are ways out of that there are ways to
rewire yourself but once a somatic habit
has been ingrained it's just like neural
Nets it's like you've got now a neural
net for that's the pathway that's the
pathway that's the pathway and then it
becomes your only pathway and we need to
open up lots of Highways for pleasure
and so that and then also it's bad sex
education I mean don't don't do what you
see I mean if you you have to have your
face like this for great oral
sex in the porn they have to do all
these other things so people can see you
know it's just the gymnastics of filming
doesn't great sex you on camera are not
very real I'm just W to tell everyone
like cheat to camera is a very very very
common thing you're
told yeah no get in there but you can't
cameras can't see what's really going on
with it's really good now act like it
feels really good yeah just keep going I
know it's been 10 minutes but you know
of course like of course it still feels
good doesn't
it it's been a half an hour but the good
the good part of it is that sometimes
people need it to Fe like sometimes if
they're not feeling arousal and they're
very vially stimulated they could use it
at the beginning you know to like get
aroused or share with a partner about
like what about you turns this on turns
you on you know like good discussions
about sexuality and what are things
you'd like to try and and being open to
creating safety for each other to
actually have the conversations about
what are the things here that do turn
you on and how can I fulfill that that's
a full yes for me um because it may not
be the thing that I'm fulfilling it may
be something underneath that that I'm
fulfilling yeah yeah yeah check it check
yourself before you wreck yourself um
okay uh Polly again all the rage these
days it doesn't seem that I I mean like
I look at it and I'm like who makes this
work but you're making this work so
you're the per you're a great person
that ask um it seems hard enough to have
one let alone multiple but hey I'm very
curious if this is also the pathway of
the future in some way like I I really
am I I'm I'm fascinated with with this
and I'm fascinated with the level of
confidence that it takes communication
honesty how does it
work I think it works with a high level
of Consciousness a lot like you said
honesty
vulnerability I choose the humans you
know I choose people really well to be
in relationship with doing your own
personal growth work if poly is really
your way some people say poly is a
lifestyle and some people say it's like
an orientation where it's more how
you're wired I've been in polyamorous
relationships for 30 years now and um
one of my relationships is over 20 two
of them or over 20 years one is 16 years
and one is five years was it even back
then I mean was there even a word for it
back then yeah it was called poly back
then relationship poly you know ethical
non- monogamy were some of the things
and we have a poly constellation and so
we're like a poly more of a family yeah
and it it works really well we have a
lot of
Harmony um it's not to say that there
aren't things that we work out you know
as things arise as things come up that
are
interpersonal but I think and people ask
me all the time like how how have you
been so successful because there aren't
a lot of successful role models that we
see out there and I think one of it is
that we all Unconditionally Love
ourselves every single one of us have
found unconditional love for
ourselves and then everybody gets it
because we have it so if if we have it
and it's not to say that you can't have
unconditional love and monogamy too like
I'm not anti- monogamy or anything like
that but that's what makes it work is
that we are all have had some level of
human Awakening we operate at a certain
level of integral Consciousness and we
love ourselves and then it's easy to
love each other because we're just being
love with each other do you think that
there's a certain kind of person
personality a way
to direct the ship for like who enters
and is successful in poly versus who
isn't like is there any way to sift
through humanity and go this is the kind
of person it works well for and this is
the kind of person it isn't and I heard
you already say Obviously a high level
of sort of conscious awareness and
Consciousness and honesty and
communication but
vulnerability yeah I think it's it's a
person who has high compersion I don't
know if you've ever heard this term
before compersion oh but I love learning
new words um so compersion means that
I'm turned on by what you're turned on
by and so for example like when my when
my lover Ian goes and he's with another
lover of his I like want to hear
everything about it and I want to I want
to know everything that happened because
it turns me on to hear about his
happiness with someone
else and so I'm turned on by him
receiving pleasure in life not it
doesn't have to be just for me and
so that I have a high level of that and
so do three Ian's the only one who did
didn't have a high level of compersion
and he would really struggle and then he
he learned over time to shift that but
that was it was a struggle for him in
the beginning and it was a struggle for
us because he would want to limit
freedom because he would have
anxiousness come up because he didn't
have that high level of compersion but
the rest of us were all like yeah like
you want to see go tell me everything
you wanted to see everyone win you want
you want people to keep winning and when
they're happy that is winning so what's
the what's the arrangement because
there's so many ways to arrange
absolutely I that's another thing is
like finding what arrangement is right
for you because for some people that's
you know and I don't like polyamory is
not more evolved than monogamy I think
some people get that wrong idea like oh
if I'm monogamous then I'm not as
evolved I
think I think practicing sacred monogamy
is just I mean it's beautiful like we
have these sacred unions and that that
can be very very sacred and and of
itself and so I just I think some people
can start to think that oh I'm not
evolved because I can't do this poly
thing well if if it's bringing you
distress then that's a sign that you're
not in the right
configuration can go that can be true
too for monogamy like I'm in distress
all the time because I want to be with
someone else I have a relationship where
we are um like we're complete he's gay
and he fell in love with me and I fell
in love with him and so we had a 20 year
we had this 20-year
relationship and it wouldn't work if we
weren't in an open situation of course
because he likes to have sex with men
but he's in love has been in love with
me for all this time we have a beautiful
relationship so do you have sex then we
have never had intercourse in our 20
years and um any level of pleasure but
we have a tantric total I mean we get
together and we just sit and we start
running energy together and then let's
the whole thing opens up and we go into
total Cosmic we dance out in the cosmos
together it's completely energetic
sexual relationship and it's the and it
is so hot and so erotic and you know and
he said to me it was really funny one
day I was like he's like yeah we just
don't meet in the sexual blueprint I was
like yeah but it's so erotic when we're
together and he's like yeah Gant you
called it the erotic blueprints I'm like
oh
yeah it's so
erotic so you know there's just things
that work too and I think sometimes
people get married and then they find
out their part's gay or they feel like
they're not sexually compatible it's
like well but you could still stay
together and love each other as long as
you didn't feel distress when your lover
is with someone else you can still raise
a family together you could still like
we have so many different forms of
relationship and it's paying attention
to love loving yourself and where do I
feel distress within this relationship
and how can we adjust and that all is
Success because you're in inating your
relationship all the time I don't think
we have one relationship we're
innovating and people who innovate
succeed in
longevity because they're willing to
innovate they're willing to have the
conversations they're willing to [__] up
and then you know fix it and
repair and that's how we operate we
operate I'm gonna mess up and that's
okay there's somewhere where I'm going
to do something and I'm going to mess up
but it's how we repair and how we
recover that actually creates even
deeper bonds with each other yeah well
because there's vulnerability in that
there's the the [__] up I'm sorry is the
crying The Mending like all of that
takes a level of vulnerability instead
of just shutting down running like all
of those things are generally easier
than facing the
[__] and we're all willing to sit in it
when we
do all willing to sit in it and see it
as our growth like okay wait a minute
I'm going to go work on
that you know we'll go we'll go work on
that thing because I think relationship
is this beautiful opportunity for us to
get even more free yeah you know
relationship and sexuality again how am
I utilizing these tools and not
mistaking the tools for the thing be it
psychedelics be it sex be it
relationship so then what's the sort
like in in ja's Dreamland of like the
Cascade of people stepping into
they into a healthy
sexual sexually healthy situation for
themselves and then with others um if
that's what they want then what does
that look like like what is the what
does the Cascade of that look like when
we all get to that
place I love that question so much it's
so delicious I feel like we're create
co-creating right now A Whole New World
um I see a world where through sexuality
and when I see when I say sex and
sexuality I want people to keep in mind
that this is a tool for your own
Awakening and that we're coming together
without
shame and with clear intention that we
are in right relationship with our
sexuality and in that we clear some of
the darker aspects on our planet that we
have had around sex the shame the
taboo
violence because we're all moving into a
state together of unconditional love for
you from you and when you have that then
everybody gets it and we're going to
treat each
other very differently when we're coming
from a place of unconditional love for
ourselves and then we and then I believe
that orgasm and pleasure and sexuality
brings World Peace when it comes from
that place we come into a peace peaceful
reality and we don't need anymore to be
playing out our
opposite because we've remembered and
we're using memory now for that opposite
and for this and so that sexuality
becomes a place of freedom of
unconditional love and Awakening on our
planet which shifts our relationship and
we move into right relationship with
everything because we realize that
everything is us
that's a that's a really dreamy place to
be and I call it butterfly
Island I like
it because it's always seems like you
know when you're in
relationship you can usually look to sex
to being one of the places that suffers
pretty quickly if something's
wrong and so it's tends to be where
you're squeezed the hardest and where
you sort of like the there's the most
tension resistance
discomfort you know like whether you're
pushing against the other person or
yourself you know there's that seems
that's a that is like one of the
ultimate hot
spots yeah I wish for everyone just to
have that that opening you know to have
that moment to have that Glimpse through
sexuality where they go into that place
we've been talking about that's
undescribable everyone to have that
moment
well it starts with taking the
test it does I got to take mine live
y'all I bravely took mine
live and um I'm glad I
did thank you yeah thank you so much for
you know being willing to have this
conversation and I just really
appreciate the depth of your questions
and the depth of thought of your
questions
because it's important I think for our
planet and for our humanity and for our
own discovery of a deepening here around
what sex is yeah yeah thank you I try
not to think about like my dad much
during this you
know like he think when I said these
things but that's the healing right it's
like on all levels we're all doing it I
came from that so and so did you and
everyone else yeah I mean we're all a
product of Sex and the moment we shame
the thing that we're all a product of
we've shamed Humanity you know I was
listening to Something in prepare in
preparing to talk to you uh some another
sexologist said that in history by
controlling sex you're controlling human
psyche because it is such a big part of
our existence 100% with that 100% I do
and especially for those of us who are
inv Volva bodies you know who identifies
as women I think
that there has been an aspect of
controlling our sexuality because our I
always warn my clients when they come
work with me I say you know because the
men are always like I want her to open
up I want her to and I'm like be careful
what you wish for because we open up the
sexuality dark got us in there
okay yep yep
exactly and then it often happens
they're like you told me about this
moment and now it has happened and
wow well like what do do like the most
common thing I was curious like what the
most common thing people come in for and
then what do they what do you end up
discovering because there's inevitably
an a certain level of comfort to come to
work with a sexologist but then there's
still layers of conditioning and fear
and and embarrassment and there's
probably something else that you
discover in the journey with them we
like oh there is is yeah it it's so
Fascinating People often come to me
because of the mismatch they feel like
you know one has what higher libido one
has lower libido one wants this the
other one doesn't want that one has the
sexual blueprint the other one's an
energetic so I often people come to me
because of the
mismatch and then what's really
interesting is watching how they often
have some game they're playing and that
pattern has been running most of their
relationship and so it'll become
apparent for me maybe like six months in
somewhere in there I've seen it now
enough the pattern that is being run
over and over and I I just call it their
game like every couple has their game
and and also single you know I'm talking
about couples who are coming to see me
but when somebody's single is coming to
see me there's a game they've been
playing as well and that that gets
revealed and once that gets revealed
then I just call what the game is and
then it becomes a decision of do we want
to keep playing this game it has been
revealed and some people can't help it
they're just like they go right back
back in they just keep playing thing
they keep doing it and then and then
they they get they can't tolerate it
anymore because it's been called out
it's been know they're like oh it just
become so painful yeah that
finally it has to be this internal
choice that they make this isn't serving
us anymore we have to stop doing this
thing that we've been doing to each
other because there's something in our
psyche that has been trying to grow and
we have not been getting it so need to
get the thing that it's trying to tell
us yeah and so you know there's a joke
that g has a process for that so we
often process through it and get the
psyche to integrate back into that part
of the psyche to integrate back
into Source back into awareness of who
they are and the beautiful thing is is
that pattern will all of our patterns
all of these these what we consider
negative emotions are just trying to
lead us back to who we are and they're
back to sour they're trying to integrate
back to source and so they always want
something really good for us but it can
be feel really painful in the moment
when we're in that pattern yeah yeah
well here's to revealing that thing so
everything can get better and you can
feel better and level up right I mean
that's the name of the game level up the
your level your Consciousness your your
state of being and open yourself up to
those ecstatic states where you can live
for you know 30 days or
so and that's really that's a whole
other thing I don't know if I'd wish any
anybody on that one that was a really
intense experience wow was it like an
orgasm for 30 days straight or was it
like a just like not in your body for 30
days it was like I liken it to this it
was like being on 10 grams of mushrooms
at times and then like taking five Meo
at
times and I hadn't taken any psychedelic
so so it was spontaneous and I thought
oh maybe somebody dose me that was what
I thought at first like somebody gave me
something and after a day and it didn't
stop I went wait a minute something else
is going on here I don't know what's
going on and then you know a little bit
fear started coming in of like what's
happening am I like what is going on I
go
back normal again yeah yeah exactly I
mean those are some of the questions
will I ever be normal again will I be
able to function am I going to have to
be taken care of because I'm in this
very different state of
Consciousness and then you know and I go
into total ego deaths like it just kept
happening over and over again and not
like just nobody there and it was really
intense so day five I started to panic
you know I started to go like wait a
minute this is like I don't want this
you know if this is like Enlightenment
my brain started going like if this is
Enlightenment I don't want it you know
like take me off the
ride um you know and then I just learned
to regulate I learned to breathe and I
learned to regulate through it and and
all the light shows and the Beautiful
sacred geometry and all the you know
just to be like okay like I guess I'm
going to have to learn to
function in this new place and see what
happens and then I called on all I have
beautiful I think this is a really
important piece for people listening
like have a team of people who either
community of people who are going to be
like okay we're holding you through this
or a team of experts who can hold you
through things my community was
incredible just being like we're here if
we have to cancel things for the next
two weeks and like make sure you eat
like we're here we're here for it and I
was having Magdalene types of
experiences I was gonna say the
energetic over here was like have your
energetic team like y hell's yeah like I
call them all the time right I mean
whether it's the nighttime prayers or
whatever the thing it's like no no no
like you call on them yep exactly
exactly so that it was you know moments
were very transpersonal where I'm like
working with Mary Magdalene and and
moments of very non-u and moments of
this beautiful geometry and so many
downloads and so many things to and
showing me where my attachments were
like oh my gosh I'm so attached to my
son and I'm so attached to my partners
and my loves and my work and I'm not
ready to give any of that up so if I
just can be continue to be a teacher
please please please I don't want to oh
that's very is very much sounds like a
soloc journey like the choosing you know
I did a five gram you said you felt like
you were on 10 and I'm like holy [__] I
was yelling on five um but there was a
point that I had to choose to come back
it was like no come this way if you want
to like I was like you want to be an
ascended Master leave form behind and I
was like no no I like it here no like I
want to be human and then I came back
and agreed to all the layers of
constructs that it took to play this
game yep and that's like to me that's
beautiful that's why we're here we came
in a body and that's that yes s that we
were talking about the very beginning
it's like yes I am [__] yes yes yes you
did too [__] yes [__] yes so cool so
more more was it more pleasure pleasure
first pleasure first [__] yes [__] yes
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button